[Music]
welcome back to
ask the expert we have today a cool dude
named andrew chow he is the owner of
boba guys
and he has many many more stores than
our very own juby but he is our
competitor
and sworn enemy in the drink boba game
and we said yo why don't we come around
why don't we have them
come over here and we'll find something
that maybe we can get along on
such as how our asian dads disapprove of
us
severely and steve now has an asian
stepdad i sure do or
he does not like her he doesn't like me
yeah so he knows the feels
okay can i ask uh you are sitting here
you are their chief rival
can you please take a sip of that and
rate it for us
okay let's do this what is your order
what is it you're
genuine you're an entrepreneur you're a
businessman you're a rival
but your genuine thoughts on that cup of
matcha we should have done like a taste
test thing
i know right yes um all right well it's
with the sunzi art of war is it like
know that enemy so
no the enemy please include branding in
your review all of it okay
let me tell you
the aloe's good i got an aloe matcha yup
the matcha is great it's high quality
because it's not too bitter not too
sweet the green's really
good you know your matcha i respect that
um
and um because a lot of matches are
overly bitter yeah yeah
and then um
not too sweet steve is easy he's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna milk this for what i live for
what about that what about the lowly
like the
branding is amazing i love the the idea
that there's different colors
it's very vibrant it's also very kind of
like iconic
um i noticed certain things like a
single color
which makes it easier to print on so
it's actually a very good economical
choice
because we do multi-color and sometimes
it's actually cost amateurs
amateurs they don't know what they're
doing i like it oh it says recycle me
absolutely totally like total literally
so that's really cute copy
copy is like the words that you write on
the thing and then um
you even got a registered trademark you
guys spent money on lawyers to get rich
dude
we got an actual trademark yeah we did
it because
we we uh decided to franchise this is
also perfect hand feel
for little asian hands see yep little
this
doesn't have this but it says minority
stereotype
it says fears uh doubts and excuses
and then you stick the straw in it
because you want to [ __ ] that say [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dog that is genius
you [ __ ] those fierce doubts and excuses
how many how do you like drink fears
doubting excuses
suck those fears yeah suck them what any
criticism
prepare daringly what do you think of
that what do you think of uh
yeah it's called it says prepare
daringly is this where
we are is this really just a consulting
my
my consulting hour is like 250 an hour
we could kind of afford it [ __ ] 250.
i gotta i
okay so really okay prepare daringly i
like
if i had to if there was a small thing
is like what do you mean by daringly
i agree and how i don't i don't
understand and how you have to support
that it's called rtb
reasons to believe so if you say
something boba guys is
next level quality bridging cultures i
have to prove it after rtb reason to
believe it
otherwise it's just it means yes it's a
random word yeah so how are you guys so
different we
well we prepare these drinks daringly
you put like a
no no no no i'm gonna get killed by my
partner that's not how no that's not how
it is
no everyone's blindfolded in the
bathroom they have to figure out a way
to make the drinks right
[Laughter]
you should do that the target thing that
you have on top yeah and then
like daringly is like you have different
dares and then
if you and you just randomly pop it and
then based on
like what do they got that's it's like
truth or dare dairy matcha
that'll be pretty hilarious how do you
compare your branding
to june b branding and like where why do
you
stand up above june b or below whichever
one you want to go with here
side by side yeah uh we stand along with
with juby actually i do know they have
great matcha so i actually because i see
it all the time like man i want to send
him matcha and get some like
some seating but i mean he's he's got
his own matcha or
all you guys have you guys i mean we can
sell you the matcha
you know what i mean but uh we can do a
collab we could be like now carrying
junebe matcha at our stores
and we can have bubble guys boba and you
know we could do a
oh that would have been a great april
fool's joke that would have we could
have
done all these trades oh that would have
been hilarious that's cool yeah april
is like literally a couple weeks away
still doing it yes it's too early
it takes time to make these like beans
sometimes yeah
but um how do you stand above or or
whatever you really want to put me on a
spot yeah absolutely just
no but honestly give us your mind no
feeling sorry if i'm watching this
if i'm watching this and i want to know
how to make my brand stand above or
below or whatever i think
this could be an interesting comparison
it's like sell me this pen right that's
the wolf of wall street so tell sell me
this boba
i think jumbies boa pros and cons it's
all about positioning owl reese which is
a famous
marketing book so positioning of june b
zoombies are accessible they're kind of
more
because of the color the way it's kind
of branded the fun type the font
typeface matters a lot yeah like that
creates a little bit more
i'm going to take technically mainstream
both of guys
given our typeface in the way or we're
much more minimalistic
in american kind of culture it looks a
little bit more bougie
so but that's where we we did the
aardvark on purpose
we use an animal which is our our logo
and you hit the nail for us we are
trying to hit the mainstream keep it
simple what's a hardboard is that at ear
it looks like the animator yeah it's
like the thing with the nose we did it
because it was obscure but familiar it
was kind of our
symbolic way of it's like a spirit
animal i thought you guys would
use uci alumni people think that i
didn't know that
i thought it was because you were
uncircumcised
[Laughter]
you have to look closely at the aardvark
check out the nose it is sticking out
it is it is like it has no skin i don't
know
damn it's circumcised all right i don't
think i've ever given up
you're gonna cut this on the the promo
clip that should be a question on every
ask the expert
we have like a navy seal coming sorry
are you circumcised
i'm glad you agree there will never be
women on the axis for a show hey yeah we
they're not experts at anything no no
i'm just kidding i just
for that there you go yeah um okay
wait it's women's history month i gotta
say that if i if i don't say something
like that i'm gonna get canceled there
you go love it
but um yeah so i don't know if it's
comparing apples to apples because they
just
appeal to a different group from a steve
trying to
make enemies among and we are enemies
but we want to keep that quiet well i
find it very interesting because you
guys are sitting next to each other why
not talk about the difference no that's
hilarious
i don't [ __ ] love it that is the
major difference though between the two
yeah i think our positioning is
different yeah i mean our we use
obviously also like we're not just
matcha
so they specialize in matcha i would
argue and we don't
and so we do more coffee and matcha so i
think in that way in in different times
your match is not as good
i'd like to say people there's a
misnomer there's this idea that
jack of all trades master of none but
back in the old days you could be
a renaissance person we tend to be a
renaissance brand we can do anything
good
yeah oh [ __ ] well good answers
what i have to say is that every time
you guys come up with new
concepts right i always wish that we
stole these ideas like the whole like
childhood snacks that we grew up with
and then you did the whole uh like the
asian market stuff
yeah and then you you i love that like
the way what is the candy
for the rest of us so like there's um
like when you go to the asian grocery
store there's like
kids snacks that you grew up with like
the like the grass
yeah hot flakes whatever white rabbit
candy whatever and they turn
these into drinks oh cool yeah so it's
like yeah growing up with reese's pieces
and then
turning that into a drink or something
like that that's really cool yeah yeah
and i was like
you [ __ ] weren't do that it's like a
blizzard
no but you're the way that you guys did
it in a set
is it wasn't just one by one yeah i
thought that was pretty packaging of it
all
yeah yeah i mean i think i mean i don't
get overly serious but a lot of it is
like if you at scale if you're one or
two shops
you're quick and nimble so you can kind
of like crank out everything so yeah
our idea is to roll across 17 18 stores
is really
hard so i have to think way in advance
right now
like you know our april fool's one that
we did we actually locked april fools a
year i'll just tell you when does this
come out
after april fools or i'm i'm all bad you
put money on it
yeah so like it's it's it's uh what did
we do this year
oh it's um i think broba guys
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's gonna be
like muscle milk and the shake and it's
like oh yeah yeah
so that's why bart just likes it bart's
like oh i'd buy that and you're like no
you're an idiot it's a joke
i know well that's a good april fool's
drum right april
well we did cannibal but that blew up
like cannabis moba we actually made it
for
vice um because they they kind of
pitched an idea
and because we were in their their kind
of portfolio thing and
we're like we can pull it off of a can
of boba and it's never been done
and because we control our own supply
chain i was like we could do it and
people
thought we faked it for the camera but
we did it like a double
joke we did it on april fool's singing
super falls but in real life we actually
filmed it already
and then when it came out in 420 which
is 20 days 19 days later
it actually was real
like that so we tend to do that so the
question is like
do you i mean a lot of it's just
planning that's all what i'll just say
it's like the bigger you get you have to
because you're
i wish i could i want to make a drink
today and i can go to market tomorrow
i can't do that so for your guys's like
initiatives and stuff how long does it
take like how much lead time do you get
oh my god
i mean when we did the was like a year
the longest one was that 88 rising thing
we did that was like [ __ ]
crazy that was long like a year no
planning uh less than a year but it was
long
it was like maybe nine months when we
first wow
you have to arrange you know deals like
that we did something with i mean
uh arclight cinemas we did stuff with
i'll tell you the one that maybe i could
start leaking is we have one with um
oh i don't know if i'm not allowed
actually they don't care but i don't
know if ours team will care but it's
we have it's likely we're going to work
with care bears oh cool
yeah so that was a huge one that's tight
they're down here actually
uh cloud coat wow and um i don't know if
i could leave this but jimmy's gonna be
doing some stuff with walt disney world
yeah i can't really um
but with all the public parks you're
going to be doing something
yeah oh in the public park i'll do lego
land oh i'll se
oh [ __ ] well we're going to be working
with a department of water and you know
water and power
it gets more complicated because if i do
something small the problem is if it's
a certain size it's this idea of scale
right yeah i do too local
does the 18 to 16 other stores they
don't make sense because it only works
for my long beach store
filmor store i didn't have to do it at
scale if i do it at skill
you work with partners that need to plan
because they got to go through license
approvals and all these things right so
like i gotta like right now on my
drive here i was approving okay i was
literally just top of mind
i was approving care bears because
supposedly we moved the cloud wrong
right so what's cool is we have our
aardvark in the universe which is
think about convincing care bears let's
just say how many
people understand what boba is inside
they're great cloud co you're amazing
but you know you have to convince them
you have to sell it internally and then
you got to get the execution and
improvement yeah so that takes
money wait how did i not make fun of
this five minutes ago you're working
with care bears with boba
yeah crazy right what's the what's that
where does your hair stand who even
comes up with that
how do you even sit there and go oh man
if only we had care bears
the collaborations they do it didn't
really make me go
weird because they do a lot of weird
stuff like i guess i just haven't seen
your business because i i only know
junebe [ __ ]
but that is so fascinating that you so
it's your aardvark character cartoon
wise
i guess i'm just as informed as the
audience maybe but like
they are going to be doing something
with care bears yeah
so the the they're owned by a company
called license uh the license or i guess
is called
um uh cloud code but it's not even about
money because generally how it works in
these deals
and um this is so as the expert so the
question that i'm assuming somebody's
going to ask is how do you do
make these collaboration deals so a lot
of times you have to think about
it it's all about incremental value
right so
it has to grow the pie as i said earlier
in the first episode
so if you grow the pie meaning if i did
a care bear's drink
and i gave them like a percentage cut of
their license
of a drink that i normally would have
already sold like it doesn't
didn't ever grow me they're just using
me for advertising in that case
you gotta pay to be on my cup i've done
that we have a lookbook we have
we come from fashion right so we had a
lookbook where we have models what i'd
love to ask you guys to be on my
next lookbook by the way you flip
through the lookbook
we have quote unquote ad placements in
them like different
like oatley and all these things or
hilton hilton's in it
and we tell people where to go if you're
traveling in california for and stay at
hilton
so that's kind of like where it works so
it's
additive but the problem is is like
where do people get money what do they
want what do we want what we need
from care bears is for me this is less
about bulba guys this is about culture
i mean we have a book we didn't name our
book the boba guys book it was
the boba book we know our role is
now in america probably if not the world
our books in different languages
is we have to grow the pie for everyone
yeah that's how we
you know and that's why generally where
most people understand now
that's what we do first five years
people hated us uh some people
asians certain people hated us because
they thought we were sellouts like no no
if you ever look closely at our platform
i'm always i'm trojan horse and culture
like
how more people know about ube and these
korean banana milk and the history of
that and slanted coffee jelly that we
did
because of us because we have four
million people starbucks and phil's
coffee
i love them they're not doing anything
like that no not even panda does into
that you're not going to history of
general styles chicken and sweet sour
and
beef or broccoli we're probably the only
in our world
the asian concept that actually has the
ability to do that so
kung fu i love them too kung fu tea but
they're not doing that they're doing
more memes
so shout outs to kung fu two they're
great um the problem
then is like how do you know how to like
like it's it's it's it's a very delicate
kind of balance of like storytelling so
you grab a market that
hasn't even doesn't know what boba is
and you're like hey
we can like infuse culture into it so
kind of
it's kind of like giving people culture
without they even know it
yeah care very specific i'll give you
i'll uh my
my co-founder might get mad but it
doesn't matter um
i'm [ __ ] hell [ __ ] yeah i love
that well he's the one executing the
license
right now is that uh ultimately when
they came to us we we have people
approach us all the time to do collabs
and so uh because we have retail that's
the one thing too people don't realize
the power of retail because a lot of
these places are digital
to do something physical is actually
rare at scale
after us they're gonna go to mcdonald's
but mcdonald's is too big not
everybody's gonna get a mcdonald's deal
or a starbucks deal
so we're like right at the right size
where if they wanted to cover all of
california they can work with us
and kind of get something out real quick
so like
you know that's why studios we work with
a24 who did a lot of great films so
that's kind of more the artsy crowd i
think with
like care bears i literally because i
grew up we grew up with them yeah i mean
i was like that's insane so when we were
negotiating that
deal was you know just a little bit of
what merch would we work together and i
said
i don't actually care what merch we make
nice uh
the it takes i had to catch up i caught
it
i really just care if
you if you
put our culture into your culture and so
most of my negotiation i'm the
negotiator i basically said
it is where i would say our fight
bulldog i was texting you guys about
being a sheepdog right like
i was like one thing i only think i
really want
is you incorporate art aardvark and boba
so
can you drink i want the care bears to
drink boba
oh never been done so your whole i could
i wish i could show you because it's on
my phone right now
yeah that's the dude that was the
license that's the art of approval i
just had to get approved
that is that is next man's gonna see
that he's gonna cry he's
like i never thought i'd live to see the
day
mr mr huggle bear he's drinking boba tea
but that's all i wanted because i want
somebody that is normal
that is that's awesome that's that's
seriously the only thing i wanted
yeah you can ask i mean cloudco who's
watching their license team
are going to be like that's literally
what andrew demanded it was the only
thing
and then but that's all you really did
work so many [ __ ] moon pies didn't
even know what the [ __ ] it was but the
ninja turtles were selling to me
is that really what moon pies were ninja
turtles ninja turtles were like yeah
they had a moon pie and i was like i
don't know what the [ __ ] this is
they had me in pizza hut yeah you know i
mean you got the
steve's got the pizza shirt yeah it's
real that's crazy
well okay we have a few questions from
our fans
because they wanted specific they had
we asked and they they i think they
actually did some research on youtube
because these
questions are very specific to you so
lauren ray's she goes
what have you learned from being an
entrepreneur that you didn't
from working for another company so
there's a couple of questions she asked
but that's a good first yeah that's a
really good one
and then she goes what would your advice
for young people
thinking about being an entrepreneur uh
straight out of college
and also would you recommend getting a
job
working for a big company first so the
first one is what have you learned from
being an entrepreneur that you didn't
from working for another company my
memory is not that good so i have you're
gonna have to repeat
okay sure sure uh entrepreneur i would
say be an entrepreneur what you learn
is how to be flexible and constantly
solve problems
because when you're in a corporate
setting like you're in a lot more
structured environment i worked at
walmart
clorox target leapfrog those are my
timbuktu those are my companies i worked
for about 12 years in corporate
and usually come into a system like it's
like uh
it's like you you're i'm a basketball
fan so like my favorite coach and leader
is coach popovich from
spurs you come into a system you know
what he's gonna give you
grit work your ass off low ego you don't
you don't have any that you're
you're out or you talk [ __ ] too yeah you
can't he does he does his team talk
popovich no no he talks [ __ ] no
he he's he's pretty respectful i would
say he's he's
he's a fiery yeah yeah and but i think
so but there's a system so when i go to
when i was at clorox
very straight system so you have less
freedom but you also have less things to
worry about i can go home and i know
roughly what i'm gonna deal with
at boba guys when you're an entrepreneur
retail entrepreneurs like us man
i somebody took a [ __ ] in front of a
door and then
my team doesn't want to pick it up so i
had to put on gloves and scoop the [ __ ]
a
human out in san francisco out of and
then put it in and then
you know like it's everything it's yeah
you're a [ __ ]
you know eight figure dude picking up
with your bare hands
oh yeah paper eight finger dude you
don't go there's no
system for this that's
who would i delegate this to yeah yeah i
need i need a uh
i need a workflow for this picking up
[ __ ] in front of our stores
that's true i noticed that when you when
you're in corporate it's this is not my
department not my job
um yeah peop like when you run in a
restaurant man it's like
yo the toilet's flooded [ __ ] everyone's
busy i'll do it how many times you're
plundering
yeah people are disgusting they are
pretty bathrooms i'm not gonna say the
best thing i've covered
kobe sucks hundreds of thousand people
died all that kind of stuff the one
thing about businesses that i think
almost every business will say
if you're watching you probably show up
in comments is
not having to clean other people's [ __ ]
because they can't come inside your
stores anymore
that actually is like silver lining
that's the one thing
because i was like how come closing
stores is so much easier and i'm
realizing
i don't got to clean other people's
bathrooms
yeah it didn't even occur to me like six
months in i was like yeah why is it so
much easier to close the store now wow
so being an entrepreneur is
learning how to be flexible work on the
fly all that
having a lot of mental it's mostly a
mental game that's why
i mean you gotta be tough you do yeah i
mean when
i do these panels and people ask me
about like starting businesses and stuff
and what would my thing be
it's um how to deal with your own
emotions because it's
like you said it's a mental game and
then you how do you deal with your own
brain
and then you gotta the bottleneck of the
business is you and how you think
you can't and you can also i mean it's
leadership because you're usually if
you're the founder ceo
yeah or founder usually and then as you
grow a ceo
usually you know like you're just as
frustrated with things too but
if you i'm in leadership like
the attitude reflects leadership right
so if you're super cynical and
everything's like oh [ __ ] this even if
you feel that
your team will pick that up oh you don't
want to complain to your team at all
you gotta you gotta not everything's
great everything's perfect guys
you're not gonna be working with care
bears talking like that yeah exactly
oh i go into those meetings hot
sometimes i'm like i'm doing it because
a landlord kind of like fired me up or
we have a personnel issue but i can't
talk about it and then i go into a
meeting like a care bears or i'm talking
to a different landlord i'm talking to
you guys
yeah and you're almost like a switch so
there's this idea that you're almost
like
i don't say role-playing everyone's like
oh andrew like like you always talk
about in my
ig like always emotions it's almost like
you're an actor i'm like my my handle is
like a
child million chameleon i'm like because
i feel even as a ceo
you have to regulate your emotions all
the time as frustrated as i could be
here's why this knowing you guys i could
talk about business which is like my
core
my core expertise but i actually am
talking in an ad
in a way that feels super free which i
almost never get
right because right now i can talk about
you guys and [ __ ] on certain ideas or
whatever like
i don't ever get to do at my own company
and if in my hat
outside well my own company they're
going to be like oh andrew's too
critical i got you know i have a
therapist and an executive coach now and
like i used to i got feedback that
andrew's intimidating
and i'm like for a ceo i'm not
intimidating i think i'm pretty casual
but then i could see why i should meet
me yeah i know i know i'm like please oh
my god
we should do a co swap i know right
you're gonna wish you had him back [ __ ]
exactly it's like yeah uncle joe's gonna
come we gotta be like the
the asian mom that's lecturing the [ __ ]
out of their kids
and like about to beat their ass and a
phone call comes and they go
hello
that's what we got to do does boba guys
have oni mancha
we did have uh onigiri yeah um
but uh pandemic but but no you guys have
good food
they still have it even during the just
gotta say you guys have
better operations so what what would be
your advice for young people thinking
about becoming an entrepreneur
straight out of college that's tough i
generally
unless you have a really good idea right
what's success what makes
an idea successful or whatever a lot of
it is team
life experience the luck um the makeup
of the market like
market viability the right timing so all
these things have to line up
i think when you come right out of
college unless you really feel like that
was all hit
i generally think even if you have the
right idea i don't know if you'll be
able to lead it
and half of entrepreneurship out of the
gates is a really good kind of
leadership foundation
because or real quick you'll find out
you have a great idea but nobody wants
to work for you and then you can't scale
then you're going to constantly be
replacing your team
i rarely meet 21 22 year olds that are
good at leadership
i happen to be i mean i'm you can tell
i'm a type a so like ever since i was
like
middle school i was in student
government and you know when i was at
berkeley like i was always like you know
undergrad i went undergrad and grad at
berkeley like
i was that kid so leadership had never
been really the issue
and getting your ass kicked was never a
problem you already knew
green belt stalin kempo
i don't want those stereotypes to be
like nerds like you know renaissance you
can do everything
says the white guy hey i'm just here to
[ __ ] poke him
no no seriously i mean but you know
that's a
true story that is actually a huge one
like like when
i was you know in school because i had
that jersey mentality like
i you know i i don't want to go super
like ethnic and
in the content like and i you know your
audience is super broad but any
immigrant kid
could feel this it's like you're always
part of this third culture two different
worlds
one thing that i really wanted to prove
was i never saw asian leaders
i never saw it is it because of where
you were at in new jersey and even
in the bay area unless you are a tech
founder ceo right now i'm in ypo uh
young presidents organizations all the
ceos across america right yeah or in the
world
35 000 it's asian consumer ceos
i rarely meet them at all these
conferences
like are never you know maybe in asia
there's asian ceos yeah
in america never saw it because
you know least likely uh demographic get
promoted
is asians right and so for me i mean i
kid around because
i mean i grew up with jerseys so i love
like i don't even get to by the way like
do a lot of trolling and insults because
my because i'm not supposed to because i
can offend people
but you guys know what that's like yeah
like the locker room talk that you wish
that you're like familiar with that you
wish you could like
you could do it more yeah if you could
do it more online but you can't yeah
i mean you're in the most softest place
the bay area oh my god
so far so like it's completely different
from new york and jersey and yeah
i mean they think la folks are just soft
so yeah i know
new york oh my that's why a lot of these
these
yeah it's like i can't even talk about
it because somebody's gonna take
something out of context
somebody will they'll take my my
hesitation
oh my god bro yeah so going back
though what you're saying about your own
company can't say necessarily what
you're thinking
i mean that's a whole separate topic
well i mean you say it also because of
you care about them and you don't
genuinely want to hurt your own team
members i get it too like i'm not saying
i'm not
when i say this too it's like it's not
because like i'm scared or anything like
that i really do care about everybody in
our fan base and i have to change the
way
the times are because i don't want to
hurt the people that love us
you know hey you don't want to put them
in your crosshairs right yeah like i've
had
you know i've had people because of
whatever reason they hated boba guys
forget they target me i can handle that
because i i am a little bit like i'm
confident
they target my team they're like why why
do you work for someone like that
that's when i'm like you guys are [ __ ]
up that's toxic right there you gotta
protect yeah your family is what i say
like
i don't mind it like i could take as
many [ __ ] yous as whatever
yeah but it's like i know within my team
people don't sign up for those kind of
you know comments yeah and they're sweet
amazing people but
nobody goes into a job which may be in
college or whatever and unless you're
the owner
no one's that vested as much as much as
i like you
um would you recommend getting a job
working for a big company
first oh that's what you did right i did
i would say what a big company teaches i
don't know if there's a right order what
a
big company teaches you is you learn how
to listen a little better i don't know
if you felt this way when you were in
the
in like military like did that give you
discipline because it's an institution
right you got to have false certain
rules do you feel like that
my thing was kind of like a double-edged
sword where like
um i think when you're in the military
and you see how the way things
operate and yes it's tougher right and
but because of how tough it is and how a
lot of like the more
like luxuries you kind of just put to
the side but like
things that you need to accomplish
happen much faster you go in the
civilian world and then now you're like
[ __ ] everyone's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you're like son of a [ __ ] but
then now and then also like so
leadership is also different too right
so it's like
it's um in military like because and i
and i think it's due to every branch has
a boot camp
so you have a of like a very fast
forward
like fat like [ __ ] fire hydra in your
mouth way of
learning how things need to be before
you join right and then now it's like
okay quite i'm i'm get with the system
no other company in the world has a boot
camp yeah so you're slowly
learning and picking things up right and
i think like so
and that's why i think a lot of veterans
like working with veterans because like
they look at each other and they already
understand
we have an understanding of how things
should be um if i have a fever but
something needs to get done i'm not
gonna go hey i'm [ __ ] entitled
where's my health insurance it's like no
this
let's [ __ ] get the job done and we'll
do whatever it takes right
so i think there's that part but the
other part i think that's cool is
uh if you just have a bunch of like like
you say type a people
the whole world is in type a and then so
you lack a whole set of communication
skills
that i think you learn about talking to
people understanding empathy and then
also like motivating in a non-toxic way
that military also can breed a very
toxic form of motivation
where people could be depressed and
burnt out they don't even know they just
think i'm such a [ __ ] high achiever
everyone's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] like 10 years later they're like
oh the [ __ ] going on with me you know
because it's so buried
it's a short-term result system that
works
but we don't know the long term it's
great for survival but yeah in real
world
it's dangerous so i think like having
that balance is good
and i think like uh um finding i think
like
like i think doing having been able to
taste both though like really helps me
understand how
people work for me at least no i would
just say 100
i just think same thing so i actually
agree with you with like i think people
should go into a corporate environment
and you learn at least
how things have been done and perfected
and honed
at least in another way so that if you
know if you want to break the rules you
know what rules to break
versus just going like imma do something
fresh and brand new but you're like but
you don't even know the history of how
things have been done
yeah yeah i mean i'm not i'm gonna
overgeneralize whether it's people i
know or
teams and everything it's just that like
there's a certain type of decorum
and etiquette which people are like oh
that sounds so corporate i'm like no
like honestly
sometimes i feel like when you don't
have any
part of institutional experience and
you're always like everything is at your
beck and call and there's no rules
anywhere
you actually ask questions that kind of
interrupt flow so it's not about
like somebody trying to press right now
everybody's anti-authority
right and i'm like it's not like
everybody's an oppressor
every ceo every owner is out to exploit
every everything in the military sounds
crazy
i know but the people paint that but the
people who paint that are generally
people who have no experience outside
anywhere else i get this whether it's
our own team member base
and all that kind of stuff they
generally i can tell when somebody kind
of like pipes up and my managers start
telling me
yeah when i was an anarchist i was a
pot-smoking high school kid with no job
experience that thought that everything
was
power hungry and greed is that really
like yeah i was a
i was a hardcore communist i studied
marx and i was just thinking that
you know my favorite band was rage
against machine and you know like i was
just
i i so i get these kids you know like
you see the the world is
full of hypocrisy and [ __ ] up yep and
you have
access the closest access you have to
rich person you want to take it out on
them
and it's like maybe you're their ideal
character of what a rich person is so
they attack you
not knowing you know other guys or not
knowing you're picking up human [ __ ]
with your hands yeah
outside of your stomach yeah they can't
they can't even afford to humanize you
right right now
but then what they're like i don't know
16 19
you know like i remember being that age
and angry and not knowing where to take
out my [ __ ] on so i have a lot of
heart for them even though i make fun of
them a lot but i've been through that
phase
yeah for sure yeah but then later you
realize oh [ __ ] you know there's a
reason for
hierarchy there's a reason for order
there's
in this and you're kind of like well duh
this makes a lot of sense when you see
it from a top bottom view like
not top as in you're better but like
everyone kind of went through the race
at different stages
and some people won first place it just
happens because you ran the fastest or
whatever
so after you get there you're like oh
duh
but then when you're down here you never
even started the race it's easy to
like be a person that's criticizing it
or whatever
you know it's actually a pretty cool
blend so uh on another asta expert
um my friend don who's like a former
special ops guy so he's like elita the
leader of the marine corps
um he wasn't delta
but i joined i joined one of his classes
because he has like this whole pool
fitness business that he's starting
and it was really cool because it's him
and a bunch of other special ops guys so
they're like probably the toughest
people you'll ever meet
and what they do is you have like a
briefing you go through the whole
workout and all of the workout is
underwater so it's
really scary like you're going to be
holding your breath for 30 seconds a
minute at a time
you come up you do burpees you jump
underneath there's like a lot of really
tough stuff because a lot of times you
feel like you're going to drown
after they're done with being like the
i'm an alpha [ __ ] this is some
hardcore [ __ ]
they do this thing called circle of
trust where everyone stands
in a circle and we hold hands and it
feels like you're almost on like a
hippie camp
and then now you talk about the most
vulnerable things that happen
so that you can talk about it so as team
members you can watch out when other
people are in trouble now awesome it's
most of them it's like the most
healthiest thing i've ever seen like
like this is how you slit someone's
throat underwater
and then you hold hands and go i was
really scared when i was holding my
friend yeah they're like talking about
the vulnerable things i'm like
how much of a [ __ ] can i be right now
because i didn't know if it was like
your definition of a [ __ ] or my
definition of [ __ ] because my
definition
is way pushier than yours yeah but isn't
it funny that we all
as men we try to bury all that [ __ ] but
then we're
we're the same people who are like hey
man if i got a problem with you i'm
gonna tell you but then if it's like if
i have a problem with myself i'm not
gonna say anything yeah like how manly
is that
but it was so cool because now we hear
each other and you go oh wow that during
that time i thought i was gonna drown
he thought he was going to drown too and
now you have this emotional support so
we're back under water for
the mission or whatever you look at each
other and you have an understanding i
got your back you got my back and it was
like
it was like very very supportive it was
cool especially in an environment where
nobody wants to say that they're afraid
yeah
yeah yeah yeah huge yeah yeah well okay
here's another
oh do you have something to add i got
one question for you real quick um so
you have scaled the business big time
you started with a pop-up shop
what would you say is how hard is it to
control your brand when you're scaling
like that
oh [ __ ] that's hard that's actually
great scaling is
there's books and books on scaling
scaling is i think the hardest thing
scaling not just operations skilling
people and leadership is pi i think the
hardest scaling culture right
because i mean you guys are all we all
really when you i watch jk
you know blow up when it was just you
guys making films and then you got you
have teams and you have different
channels right like
we ran into that not understanding what
it's like to scale
yeah and nobody there's no school for
scaling it's like even if i
i don't want to like sound like oh i
went to business school but like when i
even in business school they have no
there's no way to teach this right
because it's it's it's almost like half
learned you're like building a plane
while you're flying right so
you're it's i think that's a whole other
thing that i love talking about but it's
like a huge beast was like how do you
scale
right in your company do you guys have
like a cheap brand chief branding
officer
right now it's technically under me so
in your company the ceo is in charge of
holding on to the brand and yeah i see
yeah so but one day i think as we we're
like 350 now again
so we prior to pandemic we're like 380.
so we're about to catch back up what
does that mean
350 people sorry 350 people yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah this is actually a good segue
to one of the questions of our friends
that's a big [ __ ] question
jkjk asked do you prefer to create a
business on your own or have partners
i actually think it's great it's like it
is like marriage
if you can find the right one which is
hard if you can find that right person
though
i think you know it's better to have
some
people it's already lonely enough being
an entrepreneur what do you hate about
your co-founder
that's actually good because that's the
that's the follow-up question it's his
biggest weakness
so the follow-up question is how do you
trust someone or know they are the right
person if you do have partners
that's i think it's like marriage and
are there qualities that you look for
like do they suck dick amazingly well
no teeth
um i think i mean i want to joke on
this but it's because if he's watching i
want to be serious i won't be serious
yeah uh now you love him it's like it's
like
well i would say like it's it's hard not
to find one soul mate like my my
your wife or spouse when you're your
co-founder how do you find two soul
mates in life because your co-founder
and partner you guys right like yeah
businesses together you guys have been
around for
almost more than longer than us we've
been around for a decade how long you
guys also this is our 14th year
yeah right i respect that because
people grow different it's like marriage
though i think number one is how do you
know when you want to be married
and it very similarly is how do you know
it's someone you want to do business
with that's true
and so he's the opposite of me i'm like
a little more extroverted
like charismatic like out there and in
alpha
yeah he is like a zen monk and they call
me high priest because i kind of like
get preachy and ted talky
he's like he's like hype monk like
what's true story
he's it's not it's not insulting to him
at all he's such a kind of hermit
sometimes
uh it's like okay i'm more like phil
from wong fu and then like wes
and bin are good friends and like um
uh if you guys know the wong fu group is
is like the uh
he disappeared during christmas like two
three years ago we were like what are
you doing for holiday break i was like i
don't know
so well he did know but we didn't really
tell us they people ask me of course hey
where did ben his name has been
where did he go for uh christmas break
you know he's not coming back until
january i was like
i don't really know i think he's going
home to texas he's from texas
and then i found out later that i think
he's in in asia
so i'm like he flew he goes he checked
in at a airport i saw him tag an airport
like he's in changi airport singapore or
something i was like oh okay well
all right whatever i found out when he
gets back later he
did a retreat on a monk reservation
building like houses or villages with
monks and tanks
he's the one who the mushroom that was
him
so he's like he got into mushroom and
foraging he carries a forged knife when
he got his mushrooms yeah
i think we found joe's real best friend
yeah so
that's what i mean it's him but then he
got someone like me who's like
bombastic louder yeah but we fit well i
mean because obviously
when the cameras are off or whatever i i
turn i tone it down you have to be yeah
yeah
and he knows when i'm gone sometimes
like right now he's at headquarters
he's the one who's gonna hey ben
andrew's gone like you know
do we uh the care bears and all these
approvals we were talking about today
i mean he's the one who's like andrew
looks good looks good that's how i knew
the cloud was different
because he goes they had me redo the art
so i was like okay cool cool
so i think things like that you have to
trust so it is like marriage so now the
real question is was it like you trusted
him before so you knew you can go into
business or did the trust build yeah are
you guys
friends first or definitely friends
first you gotta date them
you gotta like know it fits the the the
you have to yeah because
it's just like marriage i think this is
the closest thing i just it's usually my
go-to answer and not [ __ ]
yeah it's just blue ball just a bunch of
blue balls so it's marriage yeah
well i mean like did you guys how long
did you guys hang out or was it with the
intent of being business partners
because most of the people i'm partnered
up with we've been friends first for
many years
so yeah he he was the uh we're talking
off camera right like he was at timbuktu
where he and i
were there in the outdoor it was like
kind of an outdoors company and they're
very few asians
so true story which i don't hate i hate
playing up the stereotype of asians you
can tell i like breaking the stereotypes
is that like we played ping pong they
had a ping on the table nobody used it
we played ping pong ah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
dammit you're playing tackle football
outside
you're like i used to be an asb and i
was playing ping pong and you're like
[ __ ] these stereotypes then i was doing
karate and [ __ ]
it's okay i opened a bubble shop oh god
damn it
i love it dude i know that's probably
what i'm trying to make up for like
breaking out of it yeah but
so so we bonded because nobody in the
office there's like this empty ping pong
table we started roughly at the same
time
and then i remember him coming over he
started like two weeks ahead of me
and nobody used this ping-pong table at
the corner of the
it's like an open warehouse office at
timbuktu in san francisco
and he goes you won't play ping pong do
you play ping pong i was like of course
i'm asian
and then um do you want to play and i
was like sure and so we were like known
well we both didn't know which i found
out later our friend lizzy said you know
you and ben are hilarious because you're
like the first time
anybody's ever used that ping-pong table
oh and i was like and it's the only two
asians
you hate those stereotypes when you
[ __ ] smack them out of existence
and you just reinforce them back up
and then so but you know what this is
another true story like i mean you can't
make this up
i i knew the stereotype because i hate
[ __ ] model minority myths which
everybody's talking about now i'm like
dude
i [ __ ] hate it that's why i went to
timbuktu it's why i did marketing
undergrad i was like i did sociology
like
what asian dude does undergrad and our
generation yeah like love sociology
psychology durkheim the stuff that we
talked about yeah yeah
marx you know cultural marxism uh
leninism
so like i think in that way i felt like
i always wanted to go against the grain
true story when we moved offices that
ping pong table got put away
our co at the time this guy tony he is
like oh we're gonna put the ping pong
table or foosball table
and i remember i was like i don't play
foosball that i want the foosball table
there
and i was like a general manager there
so i was like kind of like he'd listen
so we moved us upstairs and then so
we're pretty good at foosball
because we would we'd call ourselves
uh team asia or team taiwan and we'd
play because it's
so this guy johnny johnny from north
face like it was he's
he was like this like like white dude
that he was really good you know
fraternity probably played foosball
we didn't play so we got really good and
i remember
and people were like andrew you're
really good at a foosball i'm like it's
because
i did not want to play ping pong because
you got
good on purpose yeah that's how much you
fought against the talk to your friends
against the machine tell it to your
therapist brother
so yeah there's a there's a lot back
there that's interesting
damn okay well anthony tam says thoughts
on what makes
an authentic boba rather than cheap
powdered knockoff
there's no authenticity i have a
very i don't know i don't think
authenticity really exists in america
because and i also don't think
authenticity
is what people really strive for because
i because i'm taiwanese too
so i've been drinking boba since i was
like four years old in taiwan when you
used to eat it with the spoon and the
milk tea was warm
and if you had authentic boba it tastes
like [ __ ] compared to what they have
today
the boba today is so modernized it's so
[ __ ] good with technology and texture
it's like if you're i don't think people
know what they're searching for when
they're saying authenticity
that's me trying german beer i had a
bunch of people
because i'm you know tuber and i was
over there and they're like oh steve you
got to try this [ __ ] this is the best
[ __ ]
so i try it and it's like whatever
because out here
we had to like change like the old
recipes they don't want to change it
because it's like
in stone it's like that's the tradition
but then out here they do all kinds of
craft beers artisanal [ __ ] all and stuff
and then there's different flavors and
like i've had a way better
experience with beer it's been improved
on a million times what's funny is like
a lot of japanese things in
america it's the opposite where the
authenticity or the old ways has been
preserved
in america oh and then so japanese
people come here and go
wow this is so old even like my
grandparents don't even make it this way
anymore
so it's like flipped where it's more
authentic
authentic in america than it is back in
japan for a lot of other things like
this mochi shop in little tokyo is like
116 years old
they still make it the old way but in
japan it's all machine and
it's all automated yeah yeah i mean that
i think that question is a good question
i can you get this all the time right
like oh is this real
matcha or just real boba and uh
especially in the food business yeah all
your other guys other businesses is that
authentic i think the problem i think
it's more indicative
of the people who generally ask that if
i had to be honest
don't fully i would say they're like not
fully like
fully globalized yet yeah if you're
fully globalized you see the best pizza
in the world
in japan not enough not in italy to
japan
you know like uh which restaurant they
won that award from
the the the the new york people yeah
that or
um what's the one it was an ugly
delicious
summer samurai um one of my favorite
videos
um was what buzzfeed did with the they
had
like asian like college kids trying
panda express and they had like
like older like asian people like first
generation trying it and they all like
all the college because like this is not
ew this is not even oh my god this is
disgusting
and then and then all the older folks
are just like oh yeah this is great
exactly because like the authentic thing
is to me
it's for snobs i mean you can argue
obviously there's authentic stuff but
like our friend casey is kind of a snob
about like
if it's not authentic like i heard him
the other day this cat's like
he's like uh he's like i don't like
italian food in america
it's too you know americanized and i'm
like who the [ __ ] are you
who the [ __ ] all right gordon ramsay
think about all the italian families
that moved over here just [ __ ] did
all the recipes and [ __ ] and then but
casey just takes the entire restaurant
business for
italy and dumps it in the trash is if
it's
in america like it's just it's just a
snobby mentality
i love him by the way it's not he's like
it's the same
it's like a purist yeah purist what is
pure everything is a
adaptation of something else and food
and culture
constantly evolves and changes like
american italian food was because
they didn't have the ingredients and it
was a different region
such as like um like hawaiian food or
like hawaiian local food right like
it's a mixture of japanese filipino
chinese you know just
all it's a mix and i feel like that's
what american
america is really like yeah we just
that's i
would rather yeah spend this energy
talking about you know
people are like oh then is that
appropriative or is that you know
um appreciative i'm like that's a weird
dynamic appreciation versus
appropriation who's the who's the
gatekeeper there
what i prefer is like attribution which
is like 3a it's like not
appreciation not appropriation it's
attribution
meaning if i think of like rap genius or
genius.com or there's lyrics and you
read the lyrics and you're like oh
that's that's full
pulled from biggie that's from that's
from poc that's from j cole pulled that
from
from original jay-z i think when you see
that
and you can see where it's attributed i
think you need to know matches from
japan
and that it's very sacred or you know
certain things are
taiwanese from top and we get it from a
farm that's almost a thousand years old
and
they they um they they provide it to the
shogun in the
you know emperor so like it's a it's a
quote unquote as authentic as it can get
there yeah but then
people that don't know they'll see that
it's mixed with a new age
yeah and then they go that's not
authentic yeah they're gonna exactly
yeah but the but the actual t
is from a very often so i think that all
the lady workers on the guy walks by
they look at the ground
it's so authentic that uh that the
ladies remember that the samurais used
to roam there
the ghosts of them i'm like how
authentic you guys want this to be
it's a it's a funny debate right because
like i remember
um talking about this at a at a
university
and i was and i asked the kids this i
was like who is more authentic so
there's this guy named um
ivan ramen oh yeah i've been working yet
right he's amazing
yeah he he's a jewish guy from new york
but he went to japan
lived there and he created a ramen
restaurant in japanese speaks japanese
he
owned and operated and won awards in
japan he's world famous in japan yeah
right
so let's say he opens he opened up a
ramen shop next door to boba guys
really oh new york yeah that was always
trying to ivan yeah okay so so
personally well yeah yeah 25 clinton 23
clinton yeah so he opened so he opens up
a ramen store right and
me i'm japanese don't know [ __ ] about
ramen i love to eat it but i can open up
a ramen store right next to him
and what might suck is people will say
mine's more authentic
because i'm a japanese man and to me i'm
like is that really fair for someone
who's
put his heart and life into studying and
and creating and he's some might say
that he
uh he he he he [ __ ] it up because he
made his own style
and joe's microwaving ramen
this is real this marshawn this is
authentic
[ __ ] top problem oh yeah this one for
sure yeah
yeah my microwave japanese yeah it's so
[ __ ] funny
yeah i don't know right i really don't
know there's a there's a spot
down in um uh hacienda heights and i
think it's called
sushi show right although all those uh
chefs are mexican the sushi chefs
and a lot of people might say it's not
authentic because it's not a japanese
sushi chef right
but the owner is a japanese dude and
he's one of the biggest uh
uh fish traders in in southern
california so
he gets a [ __ ] ton of the supplies all
the supplies are from
these guys the japanese guys but the he
likes
mexican guys because he says a lot of
the japanese sushi chefs were hella um
they're a little arrogant and they they
were stuck in their ways and then he had
different things he wanted to evolve to
the restaurant and they wouldn't budge
so he says [ __ ] you guys and then he got
the guy that was maybe
working in the kitchen and he goes hey
come here and then he just taught him
and he liked that because he's like
these guys are they're ready to be
flexible
they want to learn and they're different
from these hard-headed japanese chefs
and probably some of those workers might
spin off make something and infuse
you know mexican sushi thing or whatever
would you be mad for that
yeah i wouldn't i'd be like it depends
if they're like appropriating it
like if they're like so like oh i
created a brand new thing it's the best
thing ever but he's like no
if the owner of that new place is like i
worked for this sushi place
the owner was japanese really took care
of me and i love you know
hamachi or like whatever their
yellowtail
but you know this this fish is from from
mexico or
this is uh i made a version of a al
pastor
role or whatever i think there's
something there i think that's why
i think going on it's the culture of the
policing and the yeah you know it's
that's i would say just don't write it
all i mean there are examples of
these people that [ __ ] it up completely
you know like they're not doing their
due diligence they oh you're the mahjong
ladies
right they kind of that's different
what's the word
they fetishize right the the cultures
and then they they
that they're i'm not saying that that
doesn't exist i would say that not
everybody is doing that there are it's
that's why it's it's hard you can't just
look at a picture and judge it you got
to hear the stories you got to see
what's going on but
at the end of the day man it's it's it's
just a really [ __ ] up time
okay yeah anyways uh that's all we have
for today
great conversation it's a great time to
do business though right
let's start this japanese pizza it's all
become authentic
you know i want you to microwave ramen
next to somebody i really do
they call it authentic joe's japanese
robbery why are you dumping top ramen
into boiling water
that's all i want open up the little
tokyo and then get a bunch of
buzzfeeders to come through and review
it
authentic japanese man oh he's so good
you